when i'm just at home
mom just washing my armpits with me
i'm a little kid like
bubble on my head
toys just dancing
[Music]
i've seen not dance before but i've
never seen a dance like this come on
i've seen enough dance before there's
something something something top
delicious
[Laughter]
higher rank most jamaican sentence of
all time
that's actually too funny
elephant man you know yeah wow what a
time to be alive what a time to be alive
bro that was the best time what a time
to be the elephant man was dropping
banger after black banger it remember it
was elephant versus beanie yeah it was
for you for a short stint
elephant beanie and then an elephant
said yeah
i've got dances for this man
pondering
look left look right
bro yeah
sit down
he was trying to communicate stuff
what's that bang that being a man had
with um was it maya
um
yeah this might be the one that bang is
it this is the one i always confuse with
janet jackson
i don't know he's telling me i'm sure
there's a maya song that he's got that i
always confuse with him and janet
jackson he's got a summer banger it's um
what is it bro
oh we can't play it on here but we could
have look girl damn sugar
[ __ ] damn sugar
yeah goddamn world class [ __ ]
oh tune that was a chew
um
that was a summer banger yeah we might
have to bring that back while going for
we've got a spotify playlist now right
yeah you dropped it yeah yeah
we'll add it to that guys we're going to
add that to this
right now right now
right about no trial and remember
to drop a link in the description guys
for the
smg spotify summon playlist if i forget
what's it called
smg playlist it's called the smg
playlist
spotify sng playlist you guys have been
asking for ages it did get dropped a
little while ago if you put it on
instagram but i forgot to even mention
it on here so there you go anyway guys
we're in the episode now so you already
know what you need to do you need to
stop everything right now okay you're
sitting at your desk it's probably a bit
hot and sweaty and you're thinking [ __ ]
what do you need from me james i
wouldn't need you to do is head on over
to the cool
air cond patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs you're gonna get 50 of our uh
episodes on there every thursday we're
going to drop an episode every monday
we're going to drop an episode on here
and you're thinking cool that's bet but
maybe i can't wait for thursday maybe i
want the chips as a week but i want
something in between cool you've got
three years of backlog on there guys so
much three years worth of episodes to
binge on there we were talking about the
most the episode we recorded um
for last thursday got a little bit deep
we haven't got deep in a while we
haven't we haven't he's not been looking
for the deep james of foo head they want
to know you man are a bit sensitive we
want to see it a little bit more it's
over there so we did it we got caught up
for a minute
um
so make sure you guys three pound a
month tempo a day run the p over to sng
guys it's patreon.com forward slash
shits and gigs and uh join the cult for
real for real for real for real
on top of that guys if you are watching
us on youtube please like the video if
you liked the video chirp sitting in the
comments and subscribe to the channel it
is mission 1 million subscribers now
we're very very very early in this
mission but hey we're going to shoot for
the stars we're going to believe in our
own delusions and we're going to replace
this thing with the gold plaque in no
time in no time guys so head on over
tell a friend to tell a friend to tell a
friend and let's keep the cult growing
we need to take over a small country
and uh yeah man it should be it should
be lit over there guys obviously if
you're listening to the smooth mellow
tones of your boys j money fire lord
fakes over on spotify apple podcast
google podcast
amazon music wherever you like to listen
to your podcast please
leave a nice review and a preferable
five star rating
if you can if you if you're not too
stubborn free up the five stars sucks if
so give us what we deserve
um and then without any further ado guys
my bum chum
my
cheeks mcgee
my partner in slime
um
file off ways is gonna hit us with a fun
fact for the day let's go um so today's
fun fact guys is actually about my
pharah
you heard about this
no okay so
it's something to do with him getting
deported
as well as mo farah not being his real
name oh is it not no the [ __ ] is his
real name then
this is somalia's name
yeah
yeah it is so what
because you know usually when bit mana
with a man of faking names it's an
english-sounding name
and then really it's got a somali ass
name yeah
his name is somali as hell so what the
[ __ ] is his real name
so most people know me as mo farah but
it's not my name i was born in
somaliland north of somalia as hussein
abdi kahin
when i was four my dad was killed in a
civil war i was separated from my mother
and i was brought to the uk illegally
under the name of another child mohammed
farah
so when he was when he was allowed to
enter the education system in year 7 he
told teachers he was a refugee from
somalia but eventually confided confided
in his pe teacher and revealed his true
identity and the family he was being
forced to work for
his teacher contacted social services
and helped mo farah um find another
somali family to live to live with and
escape from this hell before officially
becoming the british becoming a british
citizen sorry in the year 2000 and
embarking on his iconic olympia journey
olympic journey rather so yeah for that
for the guys i actually don't know who
mo farah is quote unquote mo farah he's
one of he's probably the fastest
long distance
runner of our time he's won like
thirty ton 13 or 19 gold medals nine
silver medals two bronze medals in a
space of
20 years
and yeah that's that's insane but he's
only just recently come out with this ra
so in the last month or so he's come out
saying mo farah is not really my name
i was smuggled in
my mum died my father smuggled him got
smuggled in lived with a family that i
didn't want to live with so none of his
family were with this family that he was
with bro
and he was work they made him work
they made him work bro and he had to be
a social service thing
took him to another family
so yeah boy that's that's insane
that's insane i don't even know how
because i wonder if he had the passion
for
running and all of these things pre
like when he was back in somalia even
though he would have been very young
like four or five or whatever before
this whole thing happened to him but all
i wonder if everything that happened to
him
spurred him on to focus on running and
focus on sports or focus on something
just outlet yeah getting out of this
bubble [ __ ] now bro i don't know
either way it's long it it literally
that is
long yeah it is it is um that's
that's so unexpected and it's also
his real name is
bear somali though yeah his real name is
of course it's even more smaller than my
pharah that's mad to be
because it's mo farah because we know
him as mo farah
i don't associate him as a somali person
yeah i know what you mean
and even though the name is his name is
mohammed farah
i never i would never call him mohammed
father no one ever says muhammad mo you
always say
yeah you say the comedian it's not only
two moes that i know you know you would
never just say mo
what is moe's name anyway
mo gilligan
just moe yeah that's what i'm saying mo
fam i don't know does anyone know that's
a good question
that's a good question
mo what's your name
what's your name youtube right what's
your name
that's [ __ ] hilarious
i have not even beat that before
i've never
i know there's more guillotine what the
[ __ ] is his name
what's your name
it can't be marvin it could be it could
be it could be
diamonds
we're intrigued yeah yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] is it
i'm sweet
i'm actually sweet
that came out of nowhere oh what's his
name gilligan but what's his real name
[ __ ] that caught me off guard oh i could
tell i saw the light bulb ping that
caught me off guard boy yeah they um
jesus this mo mohammed thing they they
they colonized his name boy yeah i know
there was a pr team out there that were
like
in this climate yeah this mohammed thing
it's just not marketing it's not
marketable it's not patented it's not
british probably
yeah mo is yeah
yeah yeah yeah m-o-e-e could be
miscreated anything yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
less less yeah wrap muhammad let's take
the hammer out yeah and just leave it in
the case of pride or pee
do you want the pride of john the paper
but you're gonna want the paper yeah
yeah so what is it
it's a moating so let's just run it as a
motif facts more money more problems
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] you know that's funny but now bro
that's that is that is actually man
confided in a pt she said fam
i couldn't be that pete i could never
beat that peter and i would resent him
for confidence yeah yeah because like
why have you given me information i've
got this weigh-in on me now it's weighed
on me for you because he's not telling
us i need to take action for this
i'm not a counsellor bro yeah i'm here
to kick born
i meant to blow a whistle and lounge
yeah i'm here to blow whistle and lie
i've got a dos job what do you come to
me about i'm a c i'm a refugee the
family that i live with are making me
work like a slave what is all this what
is all this that's it
you have to be fair i can never be a
teaching cleaning neither could you
because teachers are
teachers are parents oh they are
teachers are our parents they [ __ ]
forget that sometimes as well bro i'm
not even joking not even on a drug thing
okay they [ __ ] forget that sometimes
you just do a great job don't get me
wrong but sometimes it's like
you're my guardian right now yeah yeah
yeah guard me you know what i mean
i spend more time because when you're in
school you actually spend more time with
your teachers than you do your parents
facts you see your parents for half an
hour in the morning when you get ready
and you see maybe an hour or two at
night before you go but when you're
young especially yeah you're with your
teachers all day every day
guard me
make me feel safe and secure you just a
kiss in your teeth all the time
my teachers apart from my pee teachers
my teachers were not fans of mine
i can't even remember
um pt apart from like you said pe
teacher
my math teacher liked me because i like
i loved maths you were good at math i
remember when we met you randomly did
some math [ __ ] and i was like
i remember i knew you for two things
keyboard shortcuts and maths
didn't neither of them were adding up to
me
me and ict we got
yeah yeah control all of that yeah
literally it just made life easier yeah
oh i know but i couldn't i couldn't
remember it for nothing so it just made
my life harder keyboard shortcuts i
forgot about that
i'm hilarious [ __ ] hell yeah jesus
christ yeah but my teacher yeah my
teachers weren't really checking for me
my pt just loved me which is bad in it
because you're not supposed to like
favor students yeah yeah yeah but they
favored me massively well they they saw
the talent in it so they're gonna it's
gonna be the case they gave me awards to
me oh is it awards
they made me this special pe top that i
only i had
i was sick
and i i don't know how i would have felt
i mean i know how it felt then but
thinking about it looking at looking
back at it now i don't know i would have
felt
because
it would it makes me think
even though i feel gassed in this moment
wearing this specialty
i wonder how many [ __ ] are
bitching about me oh yeah they're like
[ __ ] this guy i wonder how many people
wanted to stab me in the back but it was
one of them things is that
it was one of those things is that no
one could really chat [ __ ] because there
weren't in our year anyway there weren't
a heap of students who were multitaskers
like pe multitaskers i was good at
everything
but there was
all the kids were just good at football
okay or rugby okay yeah yeah
i hear you whereas you had an eclectic
oh i was i was down for all sorts yeah
yeah i was here uh i didn't even
football was the only team i didn't play
for but like
i didn't really give a [ __ ] about
playing i just didn't check for football
i was good because i used to play
football every day so i was good i was
better than half the people that was on
the football team but i just i didn't i
didn't check for it so when it came to
pee time playing football
it's always in winter as well yeah yeah
in the curriculum you always play
football in the [ __ ] winter and the
[ __ ] ground was rock solid and the
ball was dead it was solid
and i was like this did this i'm not
playing i had that like what's it called
mitre do you remember yes oh [ __ ]
m-i-t-r-e
yeah yeah them [ __ ] balls you can't
header it
yes you can't hitter it
not when you're that young anyway yeah
yeah that ball will take your head off
yeah um i was on the euro euro 2012
thing 19 we were in uni 2012 202 202
yeah 202 yeah raw that's the balls i was
here for wow um
so yeah um
but yeah i used to play basketball
volleyball well i never played
volleyball table tennis in school uh
rounders like athletics i did i think in
netflix i did the triple jump relay
100 200 and javelin oh wow we never did
javelin really never the job
i don't think no we never did traveling
now mad no and um
what else did i play
some other [ __ ] rugby i did rugby
[ __ ] ain't playing rugby same but i
love the running back same cross country
i did [ __ ] hated that i did that in
year seven as well [ __ ] hated that
yeah yeah but i was too competitive
because i remember we did it in school
to call it because they did like one
cross-country race
and then we had to qualify
so we did one in pe and whoever i think
it was like the top three will qualify
to do it for the ting okay now remember
when i was running around i was thinking
there's no way i'm doing this yeah like
in front of the whole like ah because i
remember them telling me this is a
shorter version than what you're
actually going to do on the day and i'm
thinking i'm not doing this this is dead
and then but i was too competitive so
when it came to it and it was like the
final stretch i was like [ __ ] this and
you sprinted sprinted yeah won the ting
and i was like gang and then they were
like sick yeah yeah you're gonna do that
the town one was like
[ __ ] how did that go
i hated it
i think i came back 35th or something
like that
there was like 200 people right now yeah
we did one in
we did one in year seven um
but i can't remember it wasn't in our
actual school it was somewhere
and i can't remember where i came but i
just know i was like mid deep mid yeah
it was just bro i just hated breathing
like that yeah yeah it was just horrible
for me it's never been for me and never
will be yeah say we used my like my feet
used to get like pins and needles and
[ __ ] and i'd be like this is [ __ ]
horrible
um so i just didn't try on that one but
yeah man school times mad teachers they
need to check for their students a
little bit more yeah some kids are
suffering yeah yeah yeah so yeah
especially the youth that used to come
in with dirty dirty uniform or not three
days in a row
bro there was one brother in primary
school i think i was in year
five or six i want to say
i can't remember i think he listens to
this i'm not even going to say his name
dread um
but bro
this bretta stunk
stop
i'm not
i'm not even gassing you bro
this guy stunk
the whole class knew it he knew it the
teachers knew it they had misjust
[Music]
yeah that can't run
oh it used to frustrate me bro bro that
cannot run they're just sorry
it just didn't because obviously when
you're that young
you don't really process rich and poor
you just don't know everyone comes to
school when everyone goes home yeah yeah
so when i go home i know what i do yeah
yeah i shall when i clean my [ __ ] yeah
my parents washed my gums yeah so i'm
assuming your margins have been the same
thing yeah so why on earth do you stink
do you know what i mean bro you think
there's something wrong with them in it
you think you're nasty brother like you
actually sing like sort your life out
when i'm just at home mom just washing
my armpits with me i mean i'm a little
kid like
bubble on my head
toys just dancing
up
and i'm coming to school like now you
stupid move about my face you [ __ ] up
bro it just didn't make sense to me yeah
it's dread i remember when i was in like
year three or four there was a kid in my
class name was anthony
this brother smell like [ __ ]
like human [ __ ]
every single day the potency was the
same every day and it didn't make sense
because it was never better or worse it
was equal and i'm thinking is he just
shooting himself every day like what the
[ __ ] is going on the same thing no one
said nothing
and he was just at it smelling like [ __ ]
bro every day it must be um
there must be like a welfare thing that
a teachers have to abide to when it
comes to stuff like that yeah yeah i
think it has to be extreme before you
start battling parents yeah like like
come clean your yeah yeah
come to school and clean your [ __ ]
you
because it's disrupting my history class
do you know what i mean
he's getting bullied in there
i can't i can't hold this man off much
longer longer
it's your fault now
he's a ripe target he's a ripe target
i'm not gonna lie to you before i've had
my morning coffee
i'm i'm i'm finished for him sometimes
because when he raises his hand i want
to say he's gonna put your [ __ ] hand
up dirty hand down you bastard
i can't tolerate it anymore oh come on
come and pick up your [ __ ] you now
and clean him
[Laughter]
[Music]
dirty [ __ ] hand out
oh my god bro that's funny yeah fun yeah
oh [ __ ] it's dread there must be there
must be some regulation thing unless
homeboy is coming in with a black eye
yeah keep your mouth shut and mind your
business can't do a thing about it
because i'd get sacked as a teacher as
well because i want to make it parents
like to pipe up so if i build a parent
like look i think we need to have a
meeting about
like anthony's health and hygiene
they're like what what the [ __ ] you
trying to say
i'm trying to say stinks
derek
he absolutely reeks and it's disrupting
myself he's disrupting the class people
are sending for him and i'm having to
protect him on my break
my un my unpaid tea break i'm having to
waste time in the playground fending off
bullies because he [ __ ] stinks
can you please come and clean him he has
no friends yes he has
this guy can't pay for a friend
so please clean him up take him to get
his
oh and the dad will try to say something
to me i'll just
rock him
i'd have to and then now i'm left yeah
looking after this matilda you
this orphan thing because i can't send
him back in good good conscience i can't
send it back to his deadbeat dad to
stink up the place i did probably get
smacked
[Applause]
so now what am i doing and i'm just
happy it's testifying [ __ ] now oh
[ __ ] so yeah more time than probably i
can't be bothered to deal with it unless
you got bothered but yeah
having a haven't be imagine being the
stinky you
because there is always one every school
you go to every class every grade there
is the smelliest you
and it can never be my youtube i
remember
i remember there was a girl in my school
right she was a few years younger than
me yeah and
my brethren's little brother was in her
year and her name was like [ __ ] her name
was like daisy or something and then my
boy was trying to say it like oh waguan
like who do you like in your class kind
of thing
no to his little brother i was just
there i was at the house and he was
there like he was in like years six or
seven he was like no one no one i don't
like no one he's like yeah you do but
i've like who do you like and he was
trying to remember girls in his classes
like what about such-and-such she's like
he's like i don't like i don't like her
and he's very embarrassed
and then
a man said what about daisy and he said
daisy i said her breast thinks where she
breathes out of her nose
yeah
and i was like wow
that's such a specific part never heard
that before no one has
her breast is when she breathes out of
her nose over her nose that means she
[ __ ] stinks bro
her mouth doesn't even need to be
involved with this stank oh
she must have had a tooth ting yeah yeah
she must have had a tooth oh yeah some
decaying going on
for it to stink when you breathe out
your nose
i'm just exhaling and i'm broke stinking
up the mouth
that's a well-fed thing someone needs to
sort that out what do you mean it seems
to be brutal i know why do you know that
that's right
i must be sat next to her in [ __ ] art
class thinking that stinks and he's
looking at and she's like
i was waking now
he said like that's what i would be like
when i was in school when i couldn't
handle the frustration anymore yeah i
would blink like that
[Laughter]
on some morse coding i'll bring it like
that because i can't i need to react
so if i was there and i'll be squiggling
and i'm smelling satin frass yeah and
i'm like
what is that and then i look at her
she's like
i'm thinking that i would have been like
wrong
she breathing for [ __ ] noise
i would have been literally blinking so
hard i could that's my only it was my
only expression
my head would twitch like that yeah not
blink like that and i'm like oh my days
i'm gonna go mad i'm actually gonna go
[ __ ] that's hilarious bro yeah that
was best in key in my school i think i
told you about this my man there was a
break in my ear called sam he was the
stinky brother i think yeah matted hair
yes who had where you long demo were
dashing pens in his hair
yeah
pen caps and erasers
the shaving the shaving shots
the pencil shavings
that is a mistake that right there james
is a [ __ ]
mistake it wasn't the shavings
so man just collected them yeah he
shaved he sharpened his pencil collected
it and just went
in his hair
it was [ __ ] dreadful
in class in class in geography
teacher wasn't saying [ __ ] no that's
definitely a welfare team yeah that's
definitely a welfare team when it got to
this thing the
i was like enough is enough man enough
is enough i was with my boy adam king
i'll bet his full name out his name was
adam king i was like that's enough man
that's where you're bullying him now
stop like stop oh i need to stand up to
this
and he just sat there and that was
that thing was when we knew
that he knew we'd been doing it the
whole time yeah and just was too scared
to turn around and say nothing
my heart broke in my chest and i wanted
to start spinning jaws on his behalf you
know what i mean
you're the teacher yeah yeah yeah oh bro
i want to be like nah man
and i wanted to like rub your shoulders
all right but he stunk so bad if we had
that's like but but
they must get to a point even as a you
once you're like 14
if you're 14
i don't give a [ __ ] what your households
like if you're 14 and you don't and
you're getting bullied for your stank
and you're not in the yard like you know
what [ __ ] this
i'm just going to start washing my own
gums in the bath or something because
these men are running me i can't live
like this anymore
that's your business now you have to
take action you're
yeah you have wise enough
have to and i remember it was long i
remember thinking it might be a welfare
thing when by the time we made it to
year 11 randomly one time his dad picked
him up from school his dad was like 85
years old he had the oldest dad i've
ever seen
oh wow his dad was old as [ __ ] oh wow
and i remember his sister odd on sight
and in school one time oh man
i didn't even know what that meant at
the time yeah you wouldn't yeah yeah i
was in like year seven damn it's almost
like sam's sister she was gay as well
didn't make a difference but year seven
it was just yeah how are you defined
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's just how
they defined her he was like oh do you
know sam's gay sister and i was like
yeah she was like she just oh deed and i
was like
is it they're like yeah they take her
out from hospital i don't even know what
odd means bro it sounds [ __ ] damn only
until like i actually haven't thought
about that since then and so until now
i'm actually realizing like
[ __ ] did she oh dear okay yeah we were
in school
oh mad that's tough that's tough that's
oh i wouldn't want to know what that
household looks like
i wouldn't want to know
i remember we had another friend
and i went to his yard i he definitely
listens to it so i will not name and
shame okay will not i refuse to do it
okay
i remember he was his was the first yard
i ever went to
where i was like oh my god what like
this because people used to we as a
friendship thing we used to call him a
[ __ ] all the time
because he had a little bit of thank to
him but not like
not like you're the [ __ ] stinky you
yeah but like if you're a random enough
you're like just think of it bro like
come on so wait you'd call him a trump
to his face
no
no but so when he wasn't around the
friendship group people like oh we're
talking about the [ __ ]
no
well you had a nickname for him but i
won't tell you because he listens and he
knows what the nickname is of course um
but we had a nickname that was
pertaining to his his fragrance okay and
um
again i didn't know what it was about
him all right i remember his diet habits
i can't even be specific about that i
haven't because even that is enough of a
tale but
his diet habits were peak
and what you said bro you're moving like
a [ __ ] because of the stuff he used to
eat
and the times of day he used to eat it
just didn't make sense we had yeah your
parents aren't parenting you right yeah
yeah because you can't be eating
i'm not saying you can't be eating
chocolate
for breakfast
daily and i don't mean like a bitter
chocolate i mean like a bar like a
multi-pack bar thing for breakfast for
breakfast daily daily
daily like you know there's you know
when they started making those smarty
bars
the big big bar all the smarties in it
get back one of them for breakfast like
every day and we're like bro you're
eating too much chocolate
stop
he would have been popping
wasn't he just anyway moving forward his
was the first yard i ever went to yeah
well
he invited me around his yard one time
and i went in there he went he invited
me around to zr to play fight night
round four
no no [ __ ] now round three fighting out
round three it's like tangent was is one
of my
[ __ ] favorite games of all time yeah
elite level fighting game
and i was telling him i will smack you
up at fight night yeah and he was like
bet my house this evening let's go
long story short tumped him to pieces
to pieces to the point where he was like
what controls are you using
yeah to pieces yeah
um so anyway
um
his was the first one that actually went
in the yard and looking at the state of
the yard i was like ah
ra that it explains
everything
because your mom just ain't active in
here
i wouldn't be surprised if she doesn't
even live here yeah did you have
siblings
i feel like he had an older brother the
brother was much older but um he had an
older brother i think when we were in
like year seven his older brother was
like year 11. oh wow yeah so when by the
time i went around his house was
probably like year 10 his brother was
[ __ ] long gone oh yeah yeah long gone
um
but yeah the yard was a state bro a
[ __ ] state
like the kitchen
like just dirt like you know when you
watch those hoarding shows and [ __ ] just
dirty [ __ ] everywhere bro flies and
stuff like all the sofas were just
smothered with like dirty clothes and
everything you bet you literally
couldn't see the floor
and i was like wow where did you play
this game brother in his room what was
his room like
busted as well but he just moved some
stuff
down yeah but he was he was oblivious to
him
that's his life yeah and i was like [ __ ]
bro your house is disgusting i didn't
say that i wasn't coming home yeah and
then i didn't i didn't want to make fun
of him anymore mm-hmm because i was like
you just don't know anybody
this is your day in day out that's
that's tough man it was dread that's
half [ __ ] so yeah teachers need to step
up a little bit yeah yeah back to the
point yeah
they do because
yeah but then we just got bear use
getting stripped from their parents and
the teachers just
true true yeah teachers feel good they
got home i just think i had to speak up
i had to say something they used just
getting draped around the system
it's long it is long guys we're gonna
take a very quick break to
throw some love and pay some bills
over to the guys and girls over at man
escaped okay so guys it's hot hot now
okay it's hot hot and if you haven't
heard already it's also smooth sack
summer
my guys when you're playing in that
summer sun make sure you're escaped from
pubes to bum
my guy
that's right guys this summer to keep
your balls cool while still looking hot
with mass gate the leader in below the
belt grooming
is making sure we
uh making sure we all have a ball
this summer by giving our pants partners
everything they need to stay fresh
make sure you dive head first into
smooth sack summer by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code
sng sierra november golf that's
maskit.com code is sng sierra november
golf
manscape.com sng
20 on free shipping
guys
go over there now and uh jump on that
smooth sack summer that's that's that's
my new model that's another letter
somewhat smoother
smooth sack somewhere city boys are out
here with smooth sacks someone went up
right anyway back to the episode thank
you very much [ __ ] it up anyway i have
um hear me a dilemma oh there's someone
sent in
so i'm gonna go for it okay
he started off the mess of which you man
i need help
okay i already remember which one this
is now yeah you man i need help yeah
i think i've fallen in love with my best
friend's childhood crush
okay
right i think we've had a couple of
these recently we have
context i met this girl because my boy
wanted me to wingman him
but when i tell you when our eyes locked
it felt
it felt like this was a sign from god
himself
the whole time when my boy is trying to
chirps
there's just disgusting amounts of eye
contact going on this would have been
your dream and nightmare at the same
time
you already know
you know me bro there's no way i could
be chirps and a girl and she's staring
at you
you'd have to come you'd come clean
immediately i'll tell you once your
conversation's done yeah i'll tell you
86
86 for real for real for real she's not
the one for you bro yeah yeah i'd have
to let you know she's not good because
she's looking
[Applause]
i [ __ ] hate telling you that i know
you would oh yeah
i'm not forthcoming like you i [ __ ]
hate telling you that all right it made
me want to [ __ ] like why why even
bother talking to me
it makes me so angry yeah yeah yeah
why would you bother
yeah right you get to meet you can get
you here yeah yeah are you just am i a
gatekeeper
we're playing chess
like just tell me the truth i'm a grown
man tell me
yeah take it
right so lipid already
it's not even my thing and i'm living oh
my god [ __ ]
right uh
discussing my eye contact going on yeah
yeah well a year's passed and we've been
staying in contact
and she'd still be having me smile at my
phone
we all met up the other day and the
amount of sexual tension was
embarrassing
but but but my boy
but my boy to make sure we didn't get
together told her my rep
but my okay but my boy
to make sure me and her didn't get
together told her my reputation of
cheating
and the and i'm proud about it
what kind of boy is this
what the boy she was originally moving
to the boy that moved to her sorry
no obviously he didn't secure her
knows that she likes she likes him so
told her he's a chi and he loves
cheating he's proud to buy it wow yeah
man this could never be our friendship
group oh oh
this could have never been this yeah
this this yeah yeah it could have it
couldn't have been they couldn't because
this this is wild to me yeah rags
um i said he's not wrong
so i'm stuck yeah fam
bollywood twist he's not wrong so i'm
stuck trying to wing-man my boy with the
girl of my dreams
what do i do he's still trying to
wingman him a year later
[ __ ]
what bro what do you do what you do is
you cut your losses bro you
rags is he your boy or do you really
like this girl which one is it because
you can't have both
you literally can't have both calm there
is no way
there's a girl let's call her sinead
sinead is
feeling you
feeling you but she's i moved to her and
she's just she's been praying you for
time
moving moving me you know this she knows
this but i'm just i'm i'm what's the
word i'm just the [ __ ] catalyst
yeah yeah yeah yeah right listening
i feel like i'm the main character yeah
yeah yeah yeah cause i'm the one moving
to her yeah yeah it's been a year a year
a year
and you man are still doing googly eyes
every time we link up as a trio
big man it's me all right yeah it's me
or her you have to choose
because this makes no sense oh
fam
no
no
you men are doing up googly eyes every
time we link up fernando's and it
doesn't make sense to me
firm
on top of that i told her that oh you're
a serial cheat and you love it once you
started sniffing suspicions when you saw
the first googly eyes you're like rah
i'ma lock this out i'm snipping this in
the bud now
him you see him he's a [ __ ] g he's a
cheat and he loves it he loves cheating
he's proud of it
and you're not even lying as well which
is straight face
straight face mad
and she's like i'll swear okay that's
that's even madder to me because he's
willing to sell out his own boy for gal
fam
i just dipped in just eating i'm willing
to sell you out for some [ __ ] yeah yeah
right right oh this is nuts and i know
you've said it and i've not even
confronted you about it you're still
trying to [ __ ]
this is mad
this is mad
nobody's friends here they're all snakes
the yeah it's just a tart as well
the yeah not saying nothing
as far as we know she hasn't said
anything to anyone
nah
yeah yeah this could have been one of
the wildest ones you've read yeah yeah
yeah
upon deepening it it is mad wow
everyone's snaking everything
all of you need to leave yeah all of you
need to go your separate ways car if one
of you go with and if one of you get
with her it's done i was tormented
you can't be boys with me and foreign
can never talk to her again because
she's mine now yeah yeah because i was
willing to snake you regardless yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
should you like me
and if she goes with you i'm devastated
100 i will never speak to you again and
i'd want to fight her because you've
wasted a year of my life do you know
what i mean
oh
that's not to me it is mad bro
everyone's a [ __ ] snake she's a dirty
little jezebel because she's like parlor
she she's a [ __ ] harlot that's what
she is
wow [ __ ] of babylon the [ __ ] of
babylon wow forced in the fires of sodom
and gomorrah
what a little [ __ ] wow he just [ __ ]
sits there and watches mandem scratch
just fight for her yeah yeah yeah she
loves all of it she does um but
big man literally what phil said earlier
cut your losses
you let your brethren tell the girl he
likes my friend over there that you
fancy is a worthless cheat and he's
proud about it so whatever you think you
man i've got lots because i'm trying to
connect
and you're sat there
dealing with it knowing that he slagged
you off to this random girl you're right
you're willing to you're willing to slag
me off to a [ __ ] girl
a stranger unprovoked by the way facts
unprovoked on based on the suspicion
that she might like me you threw me
under the bus
i promised you i'd fight you for you
i promise you i'd fight you
i promise you is it you've exited
it right now i'm there
i promise you that can never make its
way back to me
because i would rate you so lowly yeah
yeah i'd fight you with open hands
i wouldn't even waste time clenching a
fist for you i'll smack you about like
the little [ __ ] that you are
in front of your [ __ ] misses as well
[Laughter]
that word piss me off so much the
betrayal
betrayal deniable betrayal
it can't that can't run and you plus
i'm a [ __ ] betrayer because me and
i've been texting
for a year
whilst i'm wing-banging you this whole
thing is a pallava nah now all of you
man none of your bedrooms none of you
are getting together to scrap the whole
thing oh ting there's no
there's no right answer yeah there's no
loyalty in this group [ __ ] man oh my god
must have short they must have thought
she was an absolute badass oh she must
be [ __ ]
pang she must be but still yeah yeah
this if this was this is how you men
aren't boys if this is how it would have
played out if it's me and if me and
we're in a dance and food came to me
and said
bro
i [ __ ] love this girl been seeing her
around i love this girl i'm going to go
mute her and i was like gang she is peng
and you went over there and as i'm
seeing you whisper she's just staring at
me
as soon as you come back i'll say bam
lock it she's a slag lock it
what do you mean fam the whole time
you're there she's [ __ ] staring at me
and i would have my hand on your trap
and i've been pointing at her i don't
want her to see it
because this is my boy sam i would look
back in slow-mo
i would look back and slowly because it
can't be my girl yeah yeah it can't be
my sweetheart you're talking about
she was staring at me and he trusts me
enough that he knows i'm not trying [ __ ]
you would never you couldn't i would
never make this up yeah yeah she was
[ __ ] staring at me bro and i heard i
know i was i'd open it
and i heard because i wanted to know is
it really real
is she really about it she bow about it
or not so i stared the [ __ ] out of her
bro i'm not gonna but this is how i'd
have two whiskies in me yeah i've been
bro i'm not even gonna lie to you i
stayed the [ __ ] out of her i stayed the
[ __ ] out yeah bro i did because i really
want to know what she was about and she
told me with her eyes bro she's not good
for you fab
oh my goodness yeah it could it will be
done from there yeah right pretty much
be done i would just skank the night
away
[Laughter]
we'll tribal skank the night away and
that's it
we wouldn't have to speak of this ever
again that's [ __ ] hilarious you man
have wrapped this up for a year yeah and
you've ruined all the bridges you've
burnt everything
that is the wildest scenario you've ever
read on the show
and it was so short so complex at the
same time yeah yeah yeah
wow yeah yeah wow it was insane
wow that was insane yeah you guys know
what to do 86 the whole thing
flock off the whole thing it has to be
locked all of you yeah we can't we can't
stand for this this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway um i've got a trash news for you
g all right but you're hearing this
thing about ricky martin
no
no i've not integrated
ricky martin has ricky martin had a
seven month relationship with his 21
year old nephew
i knew fam pause i knew it was a
something to do
with a guy somewhere i knew some heinous
behavior with a guy somewhere
why because it's ricky martin so is it
good because it's ricky martin
what's what's he straight is it she bang
she bangs is that is tune i thought i
was in reiki iglesias is it enrique to
me not being dread they're the same
person
ricky martin and enrique and glazious
are literally making the same music
truly they're both handsome latino men
who make jazzy music for like people
embedded them
four-year-old women in benidorm love
both of them facts so i don't know who's
who facts facts facts facts wait let me
google both of them so this is ricky
martin
i thought that was enrique
what does enrique and glaciers look like
to be fair i don't even know what
enrique looks like now let me show you
oh fam this is basically the same
picture but him younger is that enrique
yeah it looks like him oh mad
man they look the same wait i need to
find some i don't want to google on my
spotify because you're going to think
i'm trying to listen to ricky martin
let me just get ricky martin tracks
because what's his
he's got a
he's got a um vk glasses so he does the
hero
um hero baby yeah yeah i remember that
one
living la vida loca okay so that's ricky
martin yeah live in la vida okay maybe
he does the shabang shibang's then
top five songs and we can close this um
hiro
baliamos i don't know what that is take
about my life don't know tired of being
sorry maybe
rhythm divine don't tell her i don't
know anything take your bon bon
limit la vida loca yeah there's
had a seven month relationship with his
21 year old nephew who is now accusing
him of domestic violence mine could face
up to 50 years in prison for incest
under puerto rican law
wow
[Applause]
after the after the complaint was made
anonymously under law 54
martin's brother eric martin revealed
the victims the victim is an artist is
the artist of the nephew dennis sanchez
blah blah
under the allegations made by the 21
year old it said that he ended a
seven-month relationship with martin and
the singer did not take it well
consistently reaching out to him and
loitering outside his home
big big ricky martin outside his
nephew's yard
said fam take me back
the allegations people the allegations
against ricky martin that led to a
process protection order are completely
false and fabricated representatives
from martin told people earlier this
month
we are very confident that when the true
facts come out in this matter our client
ricky meyer will be fully vindicated
supposedly mad
that is
insanity right
controversial mindset first of all is is
this guy of age the nephew he's 21 years
old it's 21. okay sorry i missed that
bit
secondly yeah
you know how i feel about incest yes i'm
not about it yes but but yes
why is it illegal if they're gay
because it's incest bro yeah but so what
i know it's [ __ ] but i'm just talking
about the legal right because in my head
i always thought interest was illegal
because your utes are
bound to be [ __ ]
so you can't we can't legally allow you
to be reproducing because you're just
intentionally creating disabled people
and we can't have that that's what
that's the reason i always thought
incest was illegal okay if you're gay
and you can't have kids
then as a legal perspective forget about
morality as a legal perspective i don't
understand
the
way why why we have that law
um
i don't think
reading it again i don't think it's
anything to do with obviously
incest is involved because it's his
nephew but i don't think they're
charging him with anything to do with
because i thought when you were reading
yeah you said charge it on previously
incest under the puerto rico yes it must
be in specific places so i don't think
that's everywhere oh really i don't know
i have no i let you have no idea i
literally have no idea
at least you have no idea
face up to 50 years in prison for incest
under puerto rican law mad that's man 50
years
i'm sorry in fam my heart would be and
i'll beg him for forgiveness
fam i would say whatever you need to do
to make this right just send me the bill
and i will sort it
quietly yeah quietly
bro
in less than 24 hours you can have your
life back
charge him too
that's what i said charge him back
because he was complicit yeah he was
complicit up until the until september
we started in january he fell off in
september
he was complicit
i mean
[Laughter]
you gotta charge him too man
he needs to catch the equal case as as
me we have to split 20 no way i'm going
for 50. he's getting none
what 25 it took two to tango fam
to live in la vida it took dos
that's not even fair
if i'm going down someone has to go down
as well yeah yeah yeah nah 50 [ __ ] me
james 50 years you're telling me i'm
dying in there you're telling me it's a
fact yeah yeah and i know puerto rican
prisons aren't popular
they can't be he wouldn't have like a
secluded thing they would look after him
in the wrong way
they will look ricky martin
no
long his lips are getting moved up
his lips and his throat are getting
moved up ah
long
longer
yeah yeah if he can't handle 50 years of
that i don't think handle he can't
handle the day yeah he won't he won't
make it too weak he won't make it in
there that lifestyle was just not meant
for him yeah it's not
[ __ ]
that 50 years would scare
the christ you couldn't threaten me with
that yeah you because that's that's only
when you know the severity of it yeah
yeah i'm thinking a young 18 months
i could affirm that yeah
i confirmed the thought of it yeah yeah
yeah i mean i don't know if i confirm it
yeah but first
but i'll be thinking i'll be out i'll be
out in a year and a bit exactly and we
can pick up where he looks he's not
making choose now anyway
so seize my assets for a bit yeah
let me out in 18 months and we pick up
if i have to suck at all or two in there
we'll we'll tackle that one when we come
together
it's the game
yeah but fan
50 years
years yeah i don't even think he's 50.
jen you don't think ricky martin's 50.
i'm not dying in there i promise you
that now i'm not dying in a poet puerto
rican prison oh he's he's 50 right now
he wouldn't
oh do you know the reason why you've
probably thought enrique enclaves and
rickman the same thing hold on ricky
martin's first name is enrique
oh it makes sense so it's enrique
iglesias and enrique martin enrique yeah
enrique and glaze as we came on yeah
right two different people
but yeah [ __ ] yeah last name actually
martin or is it martinez
because martin seems like he's martin
morales ah he's a middleton yeah
his wife is also or his ex-wife oh no
ex-husband i would say
pardon
would be pissed as well because he has
he's got according to this i'm looking
at his wiki he's got a spouse
married in 2017
and they've got four kids together
ra and the whole time he's just banging
his nephew
[ __ ] hell dude i just deeped bro walk
on
right
right right right
that's like saying
me and you're in a couple right me we're
gay we're in a couple we've got four
years together right yeah
and my my actual nephew my sister's son
bro
i'm topping yeah yeah
yeah bro he's not even gay yeah isn't he
i [ __ ] hope no
what do you mean
he's not gay bro
what the nephew is not gay is that what
they said
sharp is that what they said that's not
what they said bro but i'm i just don't
they were taking for seven months i'm
telling you he was gay bro
what are you talking about
what are you actually on about of course
he is seven months
i don't care who my uncle is what do you
mean
i'm telling you of course he is it's a
coincidence
but yeah he is bro come on man you're
just saying stuff now
he has to be all right hey he is that
isn't it
he is but yeah you're still topping your
sister's you that's madness yeah of
course my sister would have dropped me
time ago you weren't making it into
prison
you're not making it she would have
dropped me time ago but from where i
said that's that's not even yeah that's
not even his sister's you that's his
brother's you from what i think you said
on there
yes yo yo
my goodness he's um he's ricky
fame went to his head yeah he genuinely
thought i'm ricky martin
yeah i can have who i want when i want
how i want
wow
that is
yeah no wonder he's going to dick yeah
the brother would have said take him for
all he's got yeah oh fam brother had a
word with the jury and the judge yeah
and said
deep it actually actually
leave my son out of it but deep what i'm
about to tell you yeah yeah yeah what
the [ __ ] i'm about to tell you my
brother we grew up together he was there
at my son's christening he's watching my
son grow up he was there in the hospital
when he was born fam and then
he's been banging him
for seven months
seven months relentlessly actually deep
that
the joy would've been like
[Music]
on top of that harassing him in front of
his own yard when he said enough is
enough uncle uncle enrique when enough
is enough
he's been coming to his yard outside his
window and said take me back i want some
more
send this man away immediately
immediately
and it just says say let's say less that
actually makes [ __ ] sense
he can't go in for any less than 50.
we this man can't be let loose
he's a predator
he's an absolute predator
right let's do ig questions [ __ ] man i'm
not that's funny that knocked me
oh jesus christ
right guys so uh last week
i asked this was a new one for you this
is an interesting one yeah i saw what
the question was yeah yeah yeah
i said we've done red flags but what are
potential green flags for you we've got
some very interesting responses it's
pretty funny pretty funny
so i'm a really muff
when she's so in love with me she
believes my lies over her friends
yo i wasn't expecting that i wasn't
exaggerating that wow
oh they had
that was way funnier than i thought that
was going to be
straight off the bat
[Laughter]
yo
wow wow
dark dark bro
oh [ __ ]
i'll ignore all her red flags if he's
got sorry i'll ignore all his red flags
if he's got a dog that's all it takes is
that fun
any man can pattern that
we can all get a dog
i thought she was gonna say if he's six
nine i'm saying
we've all got a dog you could all pat a
dog wow
yeah she's simple-minded bro
when she doesn't have the confidence to
speak to other men
that's my green flag
the confidence
jesus christ
these man this is where the bastards
come out of the woodwork
the absolute bastards both male and
female yeah yeah
when she
when she cosplays big titty anime girls
[ __ ] that's funny when he begs to be
pegged
that's a green flag it's a green flag
for her
when he begs to be paid
wow
how indeed i wonder what sensation
obviously it doesn't give her a
sensation but it will just give her a
feel of dominance it's a power play yeah
because you literally don't feel a thing
yeah you literally can't see the thing
play yeah
it's probably similar to like
if a girl said to you
like
this is probably gonna get dark
but i know what you're into in a weird
way
she said grips my hair
yeah yeah yeah and like finger up my
throat do you know what i mean you
wouldn't be feeling nothing but
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah man
that's a power move rips my hand finger
[ __ ] my throat
yeah yeah yeah my fingers are long as
well
yeah she's in trouble trouble
yeah exact same thing you're not feeling
a thing
but good lord
you're feeling everything you need yeah
yeah yeah i'm literally testing the
waters yeah [ __ ] me
wow what an analogy safe for that
save for that
green flags yeah when they have a hot
older brother
[ __ ] sake fam
when he doesn't add his air forces to
his height
i'm wearing airforces right now
i've
you know what probably a red flag i've
never owned air forces in my life not a
single pair but yeah i've heard they
they step you up yeah man there's an
extra inch mini yeah i can see it inch
minimum
that's buff
when she stays hydrated so you don't
stink of piss when she squirts on you
wow
i've only just deeped it yeah yeah if
she was bare hydra dehydrated that
squirt must be yucky piss bro that's
yellow piss
yeah that's flooring there's minerals in
there
unused minerals in there nuts oh wow
not religious those jesus girls will
make you wait
when her alloys have no scratches facts
this one jokes no male best friends have
you ever heard your mum saying she's
going out with hers i didn't think so
fats
facts
facts ally
facts my words spinning right sally
my mum has never said i'm going out with
one of my male best one of her male best
friends no one's mum has no one's mom
has yeah and literally if she has to be
like
all i know is pops yeah yeah and a
couple uncles yeah yeah yeah yeah raw
okay
i'll lie damn
one chick put when she back chats your
mum on your behalf also one guy puts
that sorry
someone's green flag is when his
girlfriend
back chats his mum on his behalf
there isn't a shade of red that would
really truly acknowledge
what that would be for me hellfire red
van if my mom's chatting [ __ ] to me and
then my girlfriend pipes up pipes up
i'd be so scared of what's about to
happen james
my mum wouldn't know what to believe
yeah
my mum wouldn't know what to believe in
me
yeah yeah yeah
my mum would tell me to get out before
telling her to go oh allow
wow yeah i can imagine it if you had
take you and your thing and get out get
the [ __ ] out of my house
because if you come back here
fam
it's long
it's long when i was a teenager it's
long them things i can't run nah i can't
run never never never never
wow
one guy put when she can deep throat i
ain't having dirty little lizard licks
ever again
lizard licks
[Laughter]
they're so dead
they're so dead bro
we need to feel it all encompassing all
those
dirty little lizard lips as soon as i
read that i was like fat yeah yeah
huh a bed with bed sheets
it's a green flag ah you've darling
you've lived yeah a different realm yeah
yeah yeah she's dated boys not men boys
toddlers yeah adolescence
fam
a man that can spell
family
there's someone i know that lives
in my mom's area
we kind of somewhat grew up together um
but like separate friendship groups but
we had a a mutual
this spreader every time we used to text
and stuff like whatsapp or text message
whatever i would always read it and
some of his spellings were like
horrendous yeah i would think
it's a mistake it has to be a mistake
you know but the more and more we spoke
the more and more i realized oh this guy
just can't spell
then there was a time where he went out
with
someone that we know
from uni oh okay someone that we know
this was time ago okay coincidentally or
yes coming to delhi i don't even know
even though i can't remember how they
met maybe they met through me maybe i'm
assuming
um and then
i think they went maybe a couple dates
or whatever and then she was telling me
one of the things that annoy her so much
about him that he can't [ __ ] write a
sentence
and and you must have been like bro as
soon as she said
i thought it was just me
wow
wow
oh wow
oh they're crazy there are people even
till today they can't spell like they'll
be typing to me girls not mostly girls
not guys they'll be typing to be
thinking how are you writing this on
multiple occasions thinking this is the
right spelling yeah that's unacceptable
it's unacceptable yeah there's one chick
that can't spell amateur
really yeah
it knocks me every time she says it how
many times does she have the word
amateur she said it a few times for me
to i noticed it the first time obviously
yeah yeah yeah but here's me thinking
it's a mistake yeah yeah but i don't
know why
that's that word came up again
but she spoke exactly the same way i
can't i'm i'm a bastard when it comes to
that kind of stuff because if someone
texts me something and i would literally
i will reply what's it called
what did you say yeah what's it called
again
amateur
brah okay say less yeah cool yeah at
least now i know yeah yeah just for
confirmation every day's a school day
literally
ah fax when she has the same friendship
group for years
yeah massive green light it is a green
light a lot of girls that i know
don't have the same french boy
they just yeah hip hop
that's a common denominator yeah yeah
because i know all the other friends
that were in these groups are still
friends
you do you no one just parts ways yeah
together
[ __ ] common denominator
munching put proper communication along
with a fat wallet
[Laughter]
speaking of fat wallet oh you did see it
because i sent it to you that [ __ ]
video
of the yacht
complaining that her man didn't pay for
18
dinners
that had to have been staged it had to
have been staged that cannot be real
james bro
i would have
said you have to pay for at least you
have to pay for all my friends i don't
like broken [ __ ] or something
sometimes no one likes a broke [ __ ] i
was like
the guy behind the camera was like oh
i would have been let's go shake he said
let's go
leave her and all her friends were just
there laughing okay
big man who paid for the food then
i just don't see why you just wouldn't
pay for all of us it's my birthday i
said i understand and he was actually
trying to sympathize with him
yeah but i'm paying for you after
understanding your birthday but i'm not
you invited 18 of them i'm not paying
for your girls i'm not paying for 18
people i'm not paying for 18b as we
stand yeah rags
i'm not paying for 18
people you've lost your mind she's like
no one likes a broke [ __ ]
broke she she took it to a love with
dave
i wouldn't expect bill gates to pay for
18 man that's ridiculous where's your
money b where's your friend's step your
friends need to step their [ __ ] up
what's all this where's your friend's
money where's your friends man's money
where's your friend's sugar daddy's
money ain't no one bought money for this
meal no one i'm paying 19.
18. that's grands ram no matter where
you go for a birthday dinner no matter
where you go that's great well i
calculated on the day i remember
thinking if they had a very very modest
meal at 50 pounds ahead we're talking
about 900 pounds
before his
before his before drinks before drinks
before dessert
before yeah before water on the table
for appetizers yeah but before service
charge
yeah
tip
yeah bro grands grands
i promise you now i could have 10 mil in
the bank and no girl could convince me
to pay for 18
of her and her girls you've lost your
[ __ ] mind insane unless i've rented
out this restaurant for you
no
impossible the only person i'll probably
do that for is my child on her birthday
yeah probably the only person i'll do
that for and we're at pizza hut yeah bro
it's minimalistic yeah you know what i'm
saying these men are nobu are satin
you've lost your [ __ ] mind oh my
goodness no one likes a broke [ __ ]
i promise you would have broken up yeah
oh we would have broken up before that
because how is she confidently saying i
can't believe you're not paying for me
and my friends it would have been done
like safe what's the money you would
have paid for
i would have probably paid for her and
her best friend she has a best friend
i would have probably played for
obviously me my boy that was there let's
say it's me you my girl and let's say
your girl was there i'd pay for you for
okay you
my girl and her girl best friend that
would have been it but because it makes
sense yeah you know that makes sense
painful 16 strangers i don't even know i
just know their names yeah rags you've
lost your mind darling yeah yeah rags
are unbelievable i think i would
probably just be like i would have yeah
i would have gone to the thing and said
what's the total
what's the total cost and i would have
had a set number in my head that i'm
gonna pay
even like max like 400 pounds yeah
that's what i'm paying you man figured
out yeah i don't know who ordered what
but i'm dropping 400.
there you go the rest is on you man i
don't know who that covered yeah yeah
but i've taken care of more than any of
you you're going to be paying for that
so just [ __ ] deal with the rest of it
that's insane yeah jesus christ
all right yeah green flags yeah yeah
when he can handle his finances because
why are you continuously eating ramen
five days before payday
i've lived that life
i remember when i had when i was working
full-time
every
single payday
i would treat myself to lunch yeah yeah
i'd get nigiri galore i spent like 30
quid on sam and nigiri yeah at lunch
time i remember you telling me yeah
every time i was gassed
towards the end of the the month bro
like rice and like
minimal chicken from home
it was poor that's pee it was [ __ ]
poor maybe two cheeseburgers from
mcdonald's yeah vinda
[ __ ] and it happened month after month
after month and it's just like stop
getting the nigiri just stop getting the
negative problems stop literally just
stop doing it i couldn't help myself
i've been so bad of money in my life at
times i'm better now but like [ __ ]
hell
because you want to treat yourself
because it's been a week of poorness
yeah it's just been a week of rice and
chicken chicken yeah literally it's been
a week of struggle i deserve a treat i
deserve a nigiri yeah but family yeah
i need i need an account in my life you
don't deserve [ __ ] you don't deserve
anything yeah
but anyway yeah carry on
doing something to make money i don't
care if it's selling drugs or do-rags as
a man have a hustle
[Laughter]
this guy put when he when she has it
looks so big hands
oh
goodness me oh indeed that's specific
i've never you know what
i don't know i'm not gonna say it cause
i'll just get slagged off all right
let's see never mind say less
when i search him on google and his
arrests don't come up
she's been with convicts boy is that a
thing can you google someone to have
their rest pop up
it sounds like an american thing it must
be it's not in the uk it can't be
it can't be you can't just drapes
people's records
publicly like that
it can't be
[ __ ] when you get that bicep squeeze
from your girl on a night out
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you looking thick today boy
yes
yes ah that's a green light yo rex huh
i like my man to keep reminding me i
belong to him especially writing his
name on my body
it's toxic but i love it at the same
time yeah that's bread reminds me i
belong to you yeah that's some brent
talk yeah oh that is
that's that's yummy yeah nice yeah
that's yummy but also it's only yummy
when i'm in the mood yeah
it's only yummy we're out in public yeah
yeah yeah as soon as we're like
fam when it's 7 00 am and my alarms has
gone off yeah tell me about it shut up
shut up i've got crust in my eye yeah
yeah
just that that pnc yeah you'll never
hear that leave my mouth ah post nut
tell me you belong to me tell me i
belong to you tell me i'm yours fam i
don't care who you are right now
i literally just night i want to see you
yeah you shut up i don't even want you
here shut up go sleep on a sofa shut up
oh have some
have some [ __ ] self pride
always trying to be codependent bruh
shut up
all right i've got a few more
being able to sit in silence and not
think anything is wrong facts
massive facts massive green flag
massive green flag a father with a full
hairline so then you know he's got good
genes i won't go bold
[Laughter]
fair enough
fair enough
oh god
my auntie
sent for my dad the other day
sent
for my dad i wasn't expecting you to say
that bro tell me
tell me
out of nowhere
um because i think my dad's only now
because my dad's had a shaved head oh
almost forever yeah same um only hair
might have pop sizes eyebrows yeah
she only has eyebrows
so my dad's been shaving his head
forever yeah and um i think it's only
like the last year or so uh because his
birthday the other day only the last
year or so i've started to notice like
you know it's grow back a tiny bit if
it's ever not freshly shaven i can just
see the line it's creeping back a little
bit
and
we were at my dad's for his birthday the
other day and my dad was talking about
we'll talk about languages that you
learn at school okay and then
my
auntie went to private school
um
and she was like oh we learned latin
so we were customer like our latin yeah
and um
we were like yeah my brother was like
yeah that must have been really useful
my dad said yeah you must have
understood the harry potter books really
well like the spells because they're a
bit all based on yeah yeah yeah yeah she
said
yeah
that's what i did to your hairline
man
i cast a spell on your hairline that's
why it looks like that
unprovoked unprovoked i was like
wrong
last week this was yesterday
and i was like oh my god to be fair my
dad bounced back
he bounced back he didn't even chuck it
to her yeah he said yeah he said swear
the old
folliculus expelliarmus
he said like that i was like wrong
but found when she said i'll see you
again oh yeah
i've never heard anyone speak to my
father like that
facts facts facts i know exactly right
i've never heard my father like that
are you sure you're sat there yeah
what's gonna happen now
hilarious jokes all right a few more
i remember green flags guys yeah
all new jeans but they're torn in the
middle i like tick yeah
man said frying chicken without no she
said frying chicken without burning
himself is a green flag fair play
when he's been to prison at least once
that's so many green flags for girls
it's unbelievable as jay huss said girls
love a bad man and a soldier they do
they just they literally do you always
see you always know this is this is how
you know
the for strangely enough the girls who
love prison man always drive them around
any time i've ever seen a bra who's been
to penn yeah in a car yeah he's in the
passenger with a white blonde girl oh
driving
ten out of ten times i swear you don't
see a prisoner driving unless he's a
boss
do you know what i mean
unless he's a boss
and he's whipping a
banging thing yeah a g-class yeah if
he's like foot soldier level yeah he's
in the passenger of a corsa
or a seat leon
with a with an average looking blondie
yeah who loves prison man
she just loves that raw dog she loves
getting bang and she'll do whatever it
takes to keep getting banged yeah it's
ridiculous
all right two more no no space between
his teeth
man
wow confidently owns the fact that he
can't pronounce certain words
we've been there we've all been there
we've all been there there are words i
just can't i can't take off the dome now
yeah definitely what did i say the other
week do you remember i i don't remember
the word but i remember both of us
trying to say it i couldn't say it i
remember both of us trying to say
physically couldn't say it we had to
google it no i'm sure yeah it was um
[ __ ] what word was it
because i use the word all the time
it was like um
ah i'll never remember neither would i
yeah i physically couldn't get it out
like it was weird [ __ ] you know but yeah
that's something you have to firm it
yeah that's it that's it for this week
guys that's the question uh we go again
next week but yeah man awesome guys
thank you very very much obviously head
on over to patreon.com
catches on thursdays for a bonus episode
and as always guys love
[Music]
you